donc j'ai pu j'ai essayé de m'interposer
parce que c'est pour moi c'était
intolérable de laisser faire ça en face
de moi et de voir ses innocents ses
enfants qui sont le symbole de l'être
sans défense faire massacrer c'est un
signe du destin fou que vous soyez à ce
moment-là à Annecy mais vous savez moi
je suis catholique
je j'appelle ça la Providence ce qui
s'est passé assez symbolique pour moi on
a effectivement donc un demandeur
d'asile syrien qui a une vie pas
possible qui est en proie quelque chose
de terriblement mauvais moment où il
décide de passer à l'acte il croise la
route c'est un pèlerin catholique qui
lui essaye tant bien que mal de vivre la
foi au jour le jour qui tente de
s'interposer vous parlez de Providence
de spiritualité est-ce que vous pensez
au fond de vous-même quelqu'un
Dieu la Providence vous a placé là pour
contrecarrer les dessins de la saillant
faut rappeler que sans vous le bilan
aurait été encore plus terrible parce
que vous avez empêché si je puis dire
alors
la personne concernée par la foi ah ça
au fond de lui cette profonde conviction
et cette sensibilité à cet amour-là d'un
Dieu qui nous sauve en fait on a plus
peur pour sa vie on a surtout peur pour
celle des autres